now that christmas is over we're looking
ahead to new year's eve this week
las vegas of course is a hub for the
most events parties and shows
celebrating the new year
but because of the pandemic a lot is
changing this year 8 news now reporter
madison kimbrough joins us live tonight
with the latest on what we can expect
madison yes sasha new year's eve without
a doubt is going to look different this
year and while we all are excited about
the possibilities the new year will
bring
it's important that we celebrate safely
while maintaining our distance from
others
usually we'd see a massive party on the
strip where thousands of people
from all over the world gather to see
the over-the-top celebrations
however this year the resorts in town
will not be having their extravagant
parties
and with capacity limited to 25 percent
in restaurants
many will close early on the 31st when
it comes to fremont street it will look
a lot different than the video that you
are seeing right now from last year
there will be no live entertainment but
according to their website
some sort of celebration is still
happening wrist bands to get in are 25
dollars
and can be bought online or at downtown
casinos
just to note no permits for large
gatherings have been approved by the
state
buck gates will open at 6 pm on new
year's eve
and as for the fireworks show that will
be happening downtown
at the plaza hotel reporting live
madison kimbrough 8 news now